that James web Space Telescope results
seem to indicate that these galaxies are
more mature they're spirals they're
spinning they're doing all their things
only 390 million years after the big
bang some say the Big Bang never
happened some say the universe is twice
as old as we thought it was again Big
Bang is taken to me many things so when
I say the Big Bang model passes these
tests you have to ask me what version of
it but you the version in which we
synthesize Light Elements micr second or
two after the formation of at least our
observable universe and that lasts for
20 minutes or so makes the hydrogen
effectively tridium tyum lithium
brillium Etc and then nothing else
happens for a couple hundred billion
years until large stares start to form
the Supernova that make the elements and
the heavier elements in the P table I
get these emails all the time except
they usually say I'm not good at math
professor keing